I think there's a lot of cool stuff that's gonna happen that we just can't see because we're held back by the bounds of the past. Well, you asked what's the point Jared. You asked what's the point of all our work. And the point is everything gets better. Just like when I look back to when I was a kid, like in the 70s, you know, it was really crummy and everything was just really crummy and boring. Right? And now everything's really bright and shiny and fun. This today is gonna look like the 70s in about 10 years. Gosh. Welcome to ADSP the Podcast episode 238 recorded on June 11th 2025. My name is Connor and today is another very short solo podcast episode pointing you towards some other podcasts that have been talking about AI LLMs and more. So as some of you know I listen to a ton of podcasts and recently there were three podcasts all roughly plus or minus on the same topic, which was AI, LLMs and the discourse
我认为未来会发生很多很酷的事情，只是我们现在还看不见，因为我们被过去的束缚所限制。好吧，你问意义何在，Jared。你问我们所做的一切工作的意义何在。意义就在于一切都在变好。就像我回想起我小时候，比如70年代，你知道，那时候真的很糟糕，一切都非常糟糕且无聊。对吧？而现在一切都非常明亮、闪耀且有趣。今天的一切在10年后看起来就像70年代一样。天哪。欢迎收听ADSP播客第238期，录制于2025年6月11日。我是Connor，今天又是另一期非常简短的个人播客，向大家推荐一些讨论AI、大语言模型及更多内容的播客。正如你们中的一些人所知，我听过很多播客，最近有三个播客大致都围绕着同一个主题，即AI、大语言模型以及围绕它们的讨论。
around them and the change that is coming because of them. And with this podcast, I basically want to point you at all three of these podcast episodes across the three different podcasts because I think you should go listen to them. Specifically one of them in particular which is one of the most recent podcasts from the changelog podcast. I imagine a certain percentage of the listeners of ADSP are aware of this. They recently had on Steve Yeggy, I believe it was on June 6th or just a few days ago. And he was on for an hour and a half talking about vibe coding, the death of the IDE and more.
以及因它们而即将发生的变革。通过这期播客，我基本上是想向大家推荐这三个不同播客中的这三集，因为我认为你们应该去听听。特别是其中一集，来自Changelog播客的最新一期。我想ADSP的听众中应该有一部分人知道这个播客。他们最近邀请了Steve Yegge，我相信是在6月6日，也就是几天前。他参加了一个半小时的节目，讨论了“氛围编程”（vibe coding）、IDE的消亡等等。
And there's this clip right from the tail end of the podcast, which I'll play now. I think there's a lot of cool stuff that's gonna happen that we just can't see because we're held back by the bounds of the past. Well, you asked what's the point, Jared. You asked what's the point of all our work. And the point is everything gets better. Just like when I look back to when I was a kid,
播客结尾有一段剪辑，我现在播放一下。我认为未来会发生很多很酷的事情，只是我们现在还看不见，因为我们被过去的束缚所限制。好吧，你问意义何在，Jared。你问我们所做的一切工作的意义何在。意义就在于一切都在变好。就像我回想起我小时候，
like in the 70s, you know, it was really crummy and everything was just really crummy and boring, right? And now everything's really bright and shiny and fun. This today is going to look like the 70s in about 10 years. Gosh. And this is something that I have been talking to friends, family, my partner, my fiancee about and I think I've said this on the podcast before my dad's a journalist and He went from doing investigative reporting
比如70年代，你知道，那时候真的很糟糕，一切都非常糟糕且无聊，对吧？而现在一切都非常明亮、闪耀且有趣。今天的一切在10年后看起来就像70年代一样。天哪。这是我一直在和朋友、家人、我的伴侣、我的未婚妻讨论的事情，我想我在播客里也说过，我父亲是一名记者，他从做调查报道，
basically by Going to different libraries. I grew up in a small town in northern British Columbia called Prince George. There is the public the Prince George Public Library, but then there's also two different libraries Via the colleges and universities. There's the UNBC library and the College of New Caledonia library Shout out to the education institutions of Prince George and I have memories of going along with my father to all three of these different libraries Because they had different books and you could do different types of research based on these books That's how investigative reporting used to be done. I remember one time, I think it was at CNC, the local college, he had these like microfilms and you'd have to pull them get the, you know,
基本上是通过去不同的图书馆。我在不列颠哥伦比亚省北部的一个小镇乔治王子城长大。那里有乔治王子城公共图书馆，但还有两所学院和大学的图书馆。有北不列颠哥伦比亚大学（UNBC）图书馆和新喀里多尼亚学院图书馆。向乔治王子城的教育机构致敬。我记得小时候跟着父亲去过这三个不同的图书馆，因为它们有不同的书籍，你可以根据这些书进行不同类型的研究。这就是过去做调查报道的方式。我记得有一次，我想是在当地的学院CNC，他有这些缩微胶片，你必须让，你知道，
librarians to pull them up from the back and then you had these machines and you'd be right, you'd be reading, you know, old newspapers on microfilms. Anyways, I don't fully understand it. The point being is that like you'd have to go around to these different places and get different resources because the internet was not a thing. And over my father's career, how he did his job completely changed. And I remember him telling me that when Google first became a thing that you could actually use usefully, it just completely upended the way that he did his job.
图书管理员从后面把它们拿出来，然后你有这些机器，你就在那儿读，你知道，缩微胶片上的旧报纸。总之，我不太完全理解。重点是，你必须去这些不同的地方获取不同的资源，因为那时候还没有互联网。在我父亲的职业生涯中，他工作的方式发生了彻底的改变。我记得他告诉我，当谷歌第一次变得真正有用时，它彻底颠覆了他工作的方式。
And he's never looked back the point being is that over a decade a couple decades the Landscape of how certain professions, you know do their job. It's unrecognizable and that clip that you know Steve is basically saying there I couldn't agree more like I don't think we can begin to fathom how different the world is going to look in a decade. And that is both exciting and scary. Anyways, I just I think people should start taking there's there's a lot of skeptics out there, which is what the the second two podcasts are talking more about. And I think if you if you listen to this podcast with Steve Yegge on ChangeLog you might be convinced and he also what you know he's a prolific writer he's
他从此再也没有回头。重点是，在几十年里，某些职业的工作方式的格局变得面目全非。Steve在那个片段里说的，我完全同意。我不认为我们能开始想象十年后的世界会是什么样子。这既令人兴奋又令人恐惧。总之，我认为人们应该开始……外面有很多怀疑论者，这也是后两个播客讨论更多的内容。我想如果你听了Changelog上Steve Yegge的这期播客，你可能会被说服。而且他，你知道，他是一位多产的作家，他正在
writing a book called Vibe Coding which I don't know when it's coming out but it's coming out at some point but also he wrote a very popular bog post almost a year ago I think it was back in June of 2024 called the death of the junior developer if you haven't read that I recommend you go read that as well. Interesting kind of to read it. H-having had like a year, uh, pass as well because at the time, you know, the LLM models that were out were, um, a lot less capable than the different, uh, models today, such as quad four. the different models today such as quad for the two other podcast episodes that I quickly want to mention are one from oxide and friends which I believe came out on June 4th. So just a couple days before the change log episode with Steve Yeggy this this is a podcast by Adam Levin fall and Brian Cantrell and they and other people from time to time
写一本名为《氛围编程》的书，我不知道什么时候出版，但总会出版的。此外，他大约一年前，我想是在2024年6月，写了一篇非常受欢迎的博文，叫《初级开发者的消亡》。如果你还没读过，我建议你也去读读。读起来很有趣，因为已经过去了一年，当时，你知道，现有的LLM模型比今天不同的模型（比如Claude 3.5）能力要弱得多。我想快速提到的另外两期播客是来自Oxide and Friends的，我相信是在6月4日发布的。所以就在Changelog那期Steve Yegge节目发布的前几天。这是Adam Leventhal和Bryan Cantrell的播客，他们和其他人时不时会
and they had on Steve Klaibnick who some of you will know is the co-author of the Rust programming language book as well as a number of other things current employee of Oxide and this Steve referred him as Klaibnick to disambiguate between Steve Yegge Klaibn nick wrote a blog entry recently called i am disappointed in the ai discourse just basically saying how there's like two groups of people people that are super pro ai and that people that are like it complete say that it completely doesn't work and he's basically lamenting on how it's impossible to have productive conversations with these groups of folks because they're kind of at odds with each other.
他们邀请了Steve Klabnik，你们中的一些人会知道他是《Rust编程语言》一书的合著者以及其他许多事情的作者，也是Oxide的现任员工。这位Steve被称为Klabnik，以区别于Steve Yegge。Klabnik最近写了一篇博文，题为《我对AI讨论感到失望》，基本上是说现在有两类人：一类是超级AI支持者，另一类是完全说它根本没用的人。他基本上是在感叹，与这些人进行富有成效的对话是不可能的，因为他们彼此之间存在分歧。
That was basically part one of a two part podcast, which part two happened on a different podcast called the fall through podcast. And if I didn't mention Oxide and Friends is the name of the podcast that the oxide folks do, Brian and Adam. And the fall through podcast is the reincarnation of the go time podcast Which is not a podcast that I actually really listened to until the tail end of it and they were winding that down It used to be a podcast in the changelog cinematic universe of podcasts. There's a ton of different ones Ship it I think is one of them brain
那基本上是两部分播客的第一部分，第二部分发生在另一个名为The Fall Through的播客上。如果我没提到的话，Oxide and Friends是Oxide那帮人做的播客的名字，Bryan和Adam。而The Fall Through播客是Go Time播客的转世，那不是我真正听过的播客，直到它快结束时，他们正在结束它。它曾经是Changelog播客宇宙中的一个播客。有很多不同的播客，Ship It我想是其中之一，Brain
Time I think at one point was one of them. Brain Time, I think, at one point, was one of the changelog podcasts. Anyways, the changelog podcast is the flagship podcast of that cinematic universe of podcasts. They used to have one called Go Time. JS Party, that's another big one. Go Time got wound down and the folks behind that, I think some of them went and created the Fall Through podcast and they on Monday, which I believe is June 8 June 9th, just a couple days ago, basically had on Steve Klavnik as well to continue the conversation that happened on the oxide and friends podcast. So it's just interesting to
Time我想曾经也是其中之一。Brain Time，我想曾经是Changelog播客之一。总之，Changelog播客是那个播客宇宙的旗舰播客。他们曾经有一个叫Go Time的。JS Party是另一个大牌。Go Time被停掉了，背后的那帮人，我想他们中的一些人去创建了The Fall Through播客。他们在周一，我相信是6月8日或6月9日，也就是几天前，基本上也邀请了Steve Klabnik，继续在Oxide and Friends播客上进行的对话。所以这很有趣，
hear that I think it's a very interesting conversation in 2025, June 2025 that is, and it will continue to be an interesting conversation regardless of your thoughts on AI, LLMs, how it's going to affect the world. We'll leave it there. Go check those podcasts out. We've got changelog, we've got Oxide and Friends, and we've got fall through. And if you don't want to check the podcasts out, just listen to those episodes individually and then forget that those podcasts exist if you want. And I will link, you know, all of those in the description and the show notes as well as the blog post that Steve Yegge wrote a year ago and the blog that Steve Klavnik wrote just a few days
听到这些，我认为在2025年6月这是一个非常有趣的对话，无论你对AI、大语言模型以及它将如何影响世界有什么看法，它都将继续是一个有趣的对话。我们就聊到这儿。去听听那些播客吧。我们有Changelog，我们有Oxide and Friends，还有The Fall Through。如果你不想去听那些播客，就单独听听那些集，然后如果你愿意，就忘了那些播客的存在。我会把所有这些链接放在描述和节目笔记中，以及Steve Yegge一年前写的博文和Steve Klabnik几天前写的博客。
ago. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast.
一定要在你的播客应用中或在adspthepodcast.com上查看这些节目笔记，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。
It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那不是标语。我们的标语是“充满信息碎片的混乱”。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。